for sure young Emily yes
yes how would you feel let's personalize
this
16 years from now oh God you're
40 single no man no kids but you have
your [__] together
you know money social podcast all that
how would you feel about that I think I
would be proud of myself first and
foremost that I did I am I do have my
[__] together regardless of whether or
not I have a relationship or children I
think part of me would be very upset
that I don't have those things but I
would make the best of it gotcha well
how delusional is Emily
oh she's super delusional
I mean I just think yeah yeah what makes
her delusional she's a sweet girl but
it's very sweet but it's it's no you
don't know me it's important because I
mean you have you have a lot of things
going for you but because you're on only
fans like you're going to be ruled out
for most of the guys you want and and
I'm sure that in itself is delusional
okay it's unfortunate because without it
like you probably would be a contender
for a lot of the guys you want I have a
question do you think somebody who maybe
they did do only fans maybe they were in
a position in their life where that was
their choice do you think a woman who
has done only fans can be turned and I
know the comments are going to go crazy
but do you think that it's possible for
those women to turn into like committed
wives here's my argument Saint Mary
Magdalene was a prostitute okay and she
ended up a saint so would you say that
people do have the ability to make that
decision and commit to it even if they
do have more of a promiscuous past I
mean unicorns exist but they're still
unicorns I actually asked my dad this
question I had a boyfriend that my dad
wasn't the biggest fan of and I was like
Dad you guys change like do people
change and he looked at me said yes they
get worse over time
trait you see now will probably be worse
than 10 years so choose carefully
I broke up with him
sure but like yeah internal change is
hard work like it's have you have you
really actually changed something about
yourself it's hard you can't run from
yourself yes so are there unicorns yeah
but are most guys going to stick around
to find out probably not but if they
were like a retired only fans person and
they were like I don't want to I would
say I would say better odds okay I would
say you have better odds if you pick
someone but is it probable right I
understand yeah and by the way just to
be clear so for our people in the
audience unicorns actually don't exist
yeah I was gonna say
just wearing like a birthday hat okay
well since you brought it up
um
Pearl what would you say to one of your
brothers you've got multiple brothers or
even a guy best friend who was gonna
marry
and only fans girl or some sort of sex
worker whether it's stripper is she
retired or is she cut she's currently
and or may retire when she gets married
what would you say to your brother
um and I try not to be disrespectful
because you guys are here but but it'll
be disrespectful science
but it's just like I mean I would say
run I mean that that's it's
your kid's gonna think and like and and
that shows that she's putting herself
before you because like you know you
want to have a family someday you know
you want to have a kid someday and you
don't care because you put your body on
the internet and you know they're going
to see that that's the type of girl
you're picking someone that puts herself
first and I want like for my brother I
want someone that puts the family before
themselves follow up and then I want to
get your guys perspective so we
interviewed
um a few months ago Ali Ray Ali Ray it
was a former nurse she was a nurse ICU
nurse during covid yes yes yes we
started doing only fans she went from
making 80k a year to 80k a month she's
married with kids I've met her husband
and her kids on the podcast does sex
with her husband on camera what would
you say to that girl who has now become
officially a millionaire when she was
like just an average person with her
husband she does only fans what would
you say to that
um Haram
I mean again I just think it's a
degeneracy and I just think Google Haram
real quick
I mean I just think it's degeneracy like
again it's like forbidden who yeah who
cares how much money who cares how much
money you have you can't buy class and
your whole family like is going to be
looked at a certain way and that's the
Legacy you're leaving behind but and if
your husband is okay with it you know
she married a beta because no Alpha guy
would let his [__] do that wow you know
I'm sorry I'm interested no no okay are
you gonna let your girl go on only fans
with you no because I make enough money
that I don't need you to be hoeing it up
but I'll rock around with it only if you
were a couple months I know what I'm
talking about if you were broke if you
were making 45 at one point you were
probably making average salary right at
that point if you're dating a girl
seriously for marriage would you would
you do only fans with her well here's
the deal when you're broke you're
desperate when you're desperate you're
stupid so guys who are broke
ooh they got no money they are desperate
and when you're desperate you'll do
stupid things I mean and you'll get
involved in things that maybe you
wouldn't co-sign on when you had money
money not only is money a tool and a
medium for exchange money allows you to
think bigger picture it provides Clarity
and allows you to do things that you
wouldn't necessarily do if you're living
paycheck to paycheck the some of the
beauty of money is not only you know
being able to live the lifestyle you
want buy what you want but enables you
to make better decisions and not being
like the whims of emotions like I have a
buddy of mine who is paycheck to
paycheck broke as [__] and someone
wanted to hire them and they say hey
they're paying 15 an hour he's like no
way I would never work for that I go
okay don't do it he goes
[__] it I need the money I'll do it and
like that's what money does for you it
gives you better options anyway you were
going to say about uh Haram well I mean
I understand some people use sex as a
tool to get to play but I just I think
your character is tested when you have
no money and a lot of people say that's
hypocritical because I grew up with
money and a lot of people say I don't
understand it you know fair point but
it's like my dad was broke and my dad
he's just a hard worker so I just I
don't know I just look up to men like my
dad and I know it doesn't matter how
broke we were like he would never do
that okay but do you think that also
comes from your family being like Frugal
like you said because I also grew up in
a family home where like you know things
were very well set but I didn't grow up
where they were like throwing me like
six bands a month so like for me I like
I hold I hold value in like people going
through that struggle and like even
though you're raised in a home where you
can you have the resources they're not
just given to you you know what I mean
so what's what's the question
um
[Laughter]
um what would you say
to your brothers you have a brother uh
what would you also say let's say it's
brother best friend whatever who is
going to wife up and only fans girl what
would you say to him I feel like my
brother is the type
okay there are some men who don't
there's a lot of men who don't want to
work hard there's a lot there are men
who want to be stay-at-home dads and
they're like my girl's making money I'll
easily do that majority of our friends
who are in The Adult Space are in
relationships or are married okay but so
it's like you know can I change one
answer yes there's one one of my
brothers I might say landslide do you
understand
for a certain type of guy because maybe
they don't have ambition drive work hard
enough that they're okay being kept by a
woman specifically a sex worker only
fans girl yeah so those types of men are
okay so here's my question to you how
long does that relationship last if the
girl is making well over six figures and
homie staying at home
my gut is telling me that homie unless
he's got a 12 [__] inch [__] that
guy's getting left in the dustpin of
History
even you are getting cut off yeah so my
problem is my question is even then your
brother's gonna have to make something
for himself because that dude who's
getting taken care of by a rich only
fans girl he's been about to see you
next Tuesday like see you next Tuesday
and he's going to be out the door in no
time anyway so he's gonna have to get a
job anyway yeah unless he's just totally
comfortable with being a kept man
puss ass dude
yeah I'm talking about your brother
right now
we love you Dave
[Music]
to your best guy friend who actually has
something going on in his life who's
gonna wipe up and only fans girl do you
want to take this yeah absolutely I
think I would ask him to consider like I
would with any woman what she stands for
what her morals are what her intentions
are with him and really ask him like you
said you don't want to waste anybody's
time you have to ask the important
questions that you need to ask in a
relationship does she want kids if
that's what she want does she have the
same values as him you should really be
delving into who she is as a person and
how it relates to him okay fair enough I
appreciate that so I guess my question
is this for that guy
should he be willing to look past his
girl getting naked on camera for other
men should he
why should he do that
I don't like this narrative there's one
right girl for you but you don't like
the narrative that there's no value in
women who do only fans and they lose
never say that I never said that I think
I think it's needed in society actually
but but I'm a relationship like I feel
like that's for you okay what value
would you bring to a guy by like showing
your boobs but why do you act like the
only value is what they do online it's
not like you're completely dismissing
like who somebody is as a person same
things Emily said I'll tell you I cook I
clean I just suck good dick
listen I take accountability like
there's a lot of things you can value
and I make money by showing you guys you
guys said yourself on my show that it
causes you guys trauma so why would I
tell him to pick a girl that has more
trauma we said that we said that it was
an interesting take that you brought up
the fact that it might cause trauma yeah
industry that it does cause drama for
some people but for us we've outweighed
the pros and cons and no you said that
some like when you do certain things it
causes trauma I think I said I I crossed
my own boundaries and decided after a
while I was like okay that's not where I
want to go
but that's um just me just being honest
with myself you know like you know what
let me take a step back by the way
I here's my message to you guys
I'd be
I'm friends with you guys I'm cool with
you guys I'll party with you guys I'm
friends with only friends girls I've
hooked up with only fans girls I've got
no problem with sex workers I partied
with strippers I've done the whole thing
all that love you you guys are much
needed in society you guys
you are a major major benefit for
society there's one caveat
most men should not be marrying these
types of girls there are exceptions but
most meant because I'll tell you why men
are territorial they don't want some
dude they don't want like if my girl was
naked if my girl was the hottest
stripper in the club the hottest
but she was giving lap dances to
everyone there's like a side of a man
that's like yeah I'm not good with that
number two men care about their image
and their status in society so when
they're sitting around a circle what
does your wife do what does your wife do
what does your wife do what does your
wife do oh yeah my wife is an only fans
girl they're gonna feel that from the
other men and they're gonna be like
and that's fine and that's fine but most
men are not cool
what percent what percent of men don't
give a [__] would you say just by
talking about and actually and actually
don't because men will tell you things
to get laid like for example yeah we got
to be like oh six foot like tall gingers
are my type yeah okay I'll give you my
standard answer for any type of question
like this okay and it might be higher or
lower I always implement the 80 20 rule
that's with anything okay 80 20 rule 80
of men are not going to be comfortable
with this there's going to be some
exceptions right some dudes that are
just hey I'm down for whatever what
percent of the 20 would you say make
enough money
or be okay with it and make enough well
only 90 87 make over a hundred grand
anyway sorry 13 make over 100 Grand so
87 are not going to be in your category
anyway so if you're just gonna do quick
math and you're gonna say all right if
there's a hundred guys 87 of them are
out now of those 13 okay so 80 of that
so now amazing so 10 men are out so you
have three men out of a hundred who make
over six figures that may be willing to
wife up and only fans girl not saying
it's not realistic unicorns do kind of
exist at this point but three percent of
men would be cool with this that's my
number okay what do you think
not to your right
yeah that's it drop the mic we're done
here guys Delhi uh from your perspective
would you wipe up an only fans girl no
sir you would not no and would you
reveal how much money you make a year uh
about 40 Grand so let's Okay so he makes
40 Grand he's a little above average and
do you have a girlfriend no okay now why
wouldn't your for this conversation
you're how old 23 23 yeah so you're a
young guy you don't make six figures
you're a young dude let's just say for
the state of this conversation you're an
average man okay I think you have you
happen to be above average he's a great
editor
um and he's a great friend
why wouldn't you as an average man wife
up in only fans girl what is it to you
forget about me forget about the fact
that I'm this dude I wasn't showing I
make money you're the average dude
you're playing the average dude why
would you not wipe up an only person I
just think I'm more focused on the past
I don't really want to think about that
the whole time I'm with you that you're
hitting up somebody else or maybe making
money by further flirting with somebody
else it's just not my thing at all and
there's a is there a part of you and
it's okay because I'll admit it that
maybe you're a little insecure about
that yeah he's this dude I don't know
yeah I agree yeah I don't know because
men are concerned about a woman's past
and a woman is concerned about a man's
future so what about transparency like
if the woman is like here's my only fans
login go ahead see whatever you want
like they're fully ingrained with what
they're doing and have that I feel like
that's the worst thing you could do I
don't know I feel like when it comes to
you want your man to see exact so here's
my advice to you and this is my advice
to all women once you've done it already
the cat's out the bag keep doing it yeah
meaning like no guy's gonna be like yeah
she was doing the only fans but she quit
she quit for me and she stopped the fact
that you're already doing it yeah yeah
you're labeled it only fans girl keep
rocking like my advice to you is your
friend who's how's you on the show
you've already done it yeah your titties
are on camera yeah you did it already
it'd be it'd be for the win like if not
was ever going to do this I'd say not
I know your mama I know your papa
you okay like these are the things I
would like you to consider before you do
this but once she's already gone down
that path too late she belonged to the
streets and that's it she's a street
walker at that point but I also think
like men also value privacy with their
women you know like I'm sure like a guy
wouldn't want to be like bro look at
your girl like I follow her only fans
you know so I think that's where like
men that were like because like you said
men can be insecure and they aren't
shoot I can be insecure sometimes so I
think because of that that is a big
trigger for men you know the idea of
like my homeboys watching my girl I
think that's where they get a little bit
uncomfortable and I don't know there's
value in privacy there's value in those
things so it really just depends like
the life you want and I feel like you'll
be able to find the person who will
accept that you know in certain places I
think that there's like nothing sexier
though than like a man who knows what he
wants and doesn't give a [__] and he's
really strong and who he is and his own
masculinity to not let that bother him
and there are those men out there and
but I just I just think it's selling a
dream like remember 45 one out of every
two of us is expected to be single and
childless so a lot of 20 30. so so so a
lot of girls there's no happy and ending
it's by a dog and die alone and I think
I think it sounds nice to say oh there's
someone for everyone you have you're the
right person that's just not true yeah
by the way I like you have no idea like
I respect what you guys do you guys own
it and that's amazing and if you were
gonna stop doing only fans I would say
why you're already making money you're
already killing you've already gone down
that path yeah but I don't even look at
you girls as like these only fan
terrorist women that like everybody says
[Music]
they're funny and like I mean only fans
girls can be funny likeable like cool
like but it's just you have to
understand that's how men see it yeah
and it doesn't sound nice and I'd rather
say oh there's someone for everyone that
sounds by the way I I fully endorse that
the reason I have you guys on the show
is because I think you're great I think
you're amazing we're not we're not uh
insulted right now no no no you don't
need to like explain I mean I like the
words of Africa hear me out
um like I said before I'll hang out with
you guys on part of you guys I'll bang
and only fans girl I'm just not gonna
marry them there's a big distinction
it's a big distinction so if you want
this high value man that makes 10
million dollars a year that does all
this is going to pay for all your [__]
why would he pick someone like you when
he can pick a girl that hasn't exposed
herself on camera that's the question
that you need to ask here's my final
point to you and then we'll move on
um you never know what will trigger that
man that man you're talking about this
confident man he's great he's going to
accept me for who I am all it takes is
one stupid situation to happen where his
grandma asks him I heard your
girlfriend's a hoe he's like what or
some dude shut up sends a picture sends
a picture to the group chat with all his
buddies yo and he's being funny slash a
[__] yo check out Doug's girl naked
and now all his boys and now his boys
are clowning on him so you never know
what's going on
he's not chick he's not choosing the
right men to be around if that's it
that's so true
yeah you guys are looking at it as a
woman yeah so is he also not choosing
the right Grandma yeah [__] his grandma
I hope she dies grandma
if my grandma's dead his grandma can't
be alive wow I have a question for you
Adam yeah a nice little tomato so if you
found your ideal woman and she was just
exactly what you wanted but you guys got
married you had your first kid already
and we'll say
three years into the marriage first can
first can yeah take your sip of water
um you found out that she used to you
found out she used to do only fans six
years ago but her content was deleted
but there's maybe like one or two photos
out there would you initiate a divorce
Haram
two reasons why it was three reasons why
yeah two reasons why kid you're a kid
number one number one she lied because
you best believe I'm gonna ask that
question up front Okay but you best
believe you did have you ever done only
no there's no if
no
closet I would expect every man out
there before they [__] propose to get
a married what don't I know about you
what am I gonna find out about you five
years from now that's gonna make me want
to divorce you tell me now and also
there's gonna be a prenup and if and by
the way I want her to ask me that like
before I started with valuetainment you
know what Pat asked me what he said
before you get hired
tell me everything that I'm gonna find
out right now up front I go Pat
I used to party a lot as a kid never got
in trouble I you know people will tell
you stories that Adam used to go out and
be wild but there's like there's no jail
stuff there's no nothing got no criminal
stuff I've never ripped anybody off the
worst thing you're gonna hear about me
is you know that Duke could party and
he's like
yeah bro
who's in the closet
front okay
okay question well what about the girl
nudes for free I don't know if I would
divorce her at that point three [__]
you'd marry a free [__] okay say that
question again I said what about girls
who are constantly texting dudes sexting
dudes sending nudes the most women are
doing that with men that they're
interested in yeah and they're doing it
for free and those same news have been
passed around in group chats because
well this will be this will be an answer
don't don't listen to what I do listen
to what I say okay because you girls out
there that are sending me news respect
to you keep them calm or whoever
um I'll tell you the those girls are
actually bad business women if you're
just throwing your [__] out there
would you pick a girl she's got three
bodies but she was on only fans or 50
bodies
um
if I had to pick one
I would pick
[__] yeah think about it so it's three
bodies I mean her body count yeah but
she was on only fans yes versus 50 bucks
that's a great question okay I have one
question for you she's not [__] on
only fans okay thank you my question for
you is how old is she
let's say let's say mid-20s 25
are you talking about by 25. okay so by
25 if you [__] 50 dudes
okay what if I um
I wanna know when it switches so 30 30
bodies who you picking yeah I'm now I'm
leaning towards the 30 girl now you're
okay 40 bodies but how would you know
her bodies yeah I don't know like you
wouldn't okay
and she's taking [__] literally I'm
playing games
Okay so the question is the question is
this doing only fans is worth how many
people
ten bodies 20 bodies 50 bodies what
she's doing on only face yeah does it
not would that not sway more in that
favor if she's not honestly I swear to
God in my life I've never been on only
fans so I don't know what's doing I
don't know like educate yeah I mean give
me the PG the rated R and the rated X
version uh so I know girls who have
never taken their underwear off and they
like show their boobs I know girls who
never take their underwrap and put
nipple pasties on and they do like
twerking and like new like nudes but you
don't so that's PG-13 guys I like
Playboy yeah and then then I have
friends who would just do full-blown
gangbangs
and they have to like gangbangs orgies
and then they have to like meet up with
others I'm out I'm out
of camera I'm out so three bodies and
she's been gangbang on camera
you usually have to pay a monthly
subscription most girls because it's
good for good for business it's bad for
business to put your nudes out there for
free or even after a subscription you
have the pay-per-view messages so like
like my feed looks like someone's normal
Instagram feed like me and bikinis Okay
and like I don't know whatever you keep
doing you I don't know I got to get back
to on that we got Alaska before the end
we got I told you like what is it 130
around 30 he he picked the girl with the
30 Bodies Okay 50 he he was probably the
only fans girl if you did 50 lie like
what are you talking about as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible